ing
hey I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's May 18 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you haven't joined us yet I implore
you people that's right implore
i-m-p-l-o-r-e you to join us at
reubenreport.locals.com for the post
game show for ad free content for Early
Access live chats and other goodies the
theme of the show today ladies and
gentlemen is that if you have ever drank
a beer or you know anyone who's ever
drank a beer you're gay that's right
you're gay you might be married to
someone of the opposite sex you may
never have done anything gay so to speak
but you're pretty gay and uh they want
you to be gay and they're going to make
you gay through their advertising and
their beer it's all very weird and it's
not just uh beers by the way if you've
ever driven a car you're gay
beer car they said he shouldn't drink or
drive but if you've done either of these
things together separately does not
matter you're a big homo that's the one
thing and then of course we're going to
show you some solutions to this uh
onslaught of insanity that is just
everywhere I should preface at the top
of the show that I don't have a problem
if you're gay not a problem my husband's
gay not a big deal to me but you know I
don't know that every advertisement on
television has to be uh promoting the
homos so there we go uh first we will
start with an ad and then get to it uh
guys let's talk about vertical group you
know president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
that's gold and you can own it in a tax
sheltered retirement account with the
help of Birch gold that's right Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K maybe from a previous
employer into an IRA in gold and the
best part you don't pay a penny out of
pocket just visit birchgold.com Dave
today to get your free info kit they'll
hold your hand through the entire
process think about this when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold like I did Birch gold
has an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers visit birchgold.com today to
get your free info kit on gold that's
birchgold.com Dave and now back to me
okay so you've seen it we've played a
couple of these and they are just going
wild everywhere every two seconds there
is another gay beer there is another gay
car there is another gay this gay that
everything is freaking gay
very strange and by the way guys it's
only the middle of may do you know
what's coming in June that's when
everyone goes gay because it's pride
month so if you think it's getting gay
now you have no idea what you're in for
in about 12 days Bernie goes gay
everybody gets gay bite in the holster
bank anyway uh Miller Lite uh you saw
some of this we played some of their
their woke ad campaign yesterday uh Joe
Rogan had a Navy SEAL Jack car on I've
had Jack Carr author Jack Carr on the
show and they were dissecting some of
Miller lights woke ad campaign thought
we'd play a little bit of their analysis
and then we'll show you some videos
because they don't learn no one learns
well it's just in general I think it's
kind of those taking lessons from the
past and applying them going forward as
wisdom how about lessons from a week ago
I know it's not even the past it's like
a couple days ago they're gonna turn it
into most yeah that's it to brew beer
ever from Mesopotamia to the middle
they're saying women brewed beer they
said they were the first were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later how
did the industry pay homage to the
founding mothers of fear they put us in
bikinis with awesome pictures like that
as hell she looks hot yeah
I mean look at that those are great
those are great ads
this time beer made it up to women so
today Miller light is on a mission
it's really lights on a mission to make
sure no one buys their stuff
oh my goodness I'm buying it back so
that he can turn it into it for women
Brewers they're scouring the internet
buying it back yeah ladies because
that's easy to do once you get an image
up there on the internet so what is she
saying let's see compost to warps
beautiful fertilizer
interesting helps Farmers grow quality
hops yeah which has been donated to
women Brewers to make their own really
good
but there's definitely more out
there in your attic in the garage in
your parents basement send any you
got into Miller Lite and they'll turn
that into good too
oh
so here's to women because without us
there would be no fear
[Music]
oh God I hate identity politics with a
passion I really do it's pretty
interesting it's so stupid it's human
beings made beer okay
and some human beings look good in
bikinis well it's like what are we doing
it's crazy we didn't do it women do it
women do it I'd like to see a pie chart
of how many women are actually involved
in making beer or drinking I also would
like to see the pie chart of how many
women are at home making beer look the
whole ad campaign is ridiculous Rogan is
right this identity politics thing this
woke thing
I hate it with a passion and it has
destroyed so much and it's destroying
these companies from the inside we know
what wokeness through gender has done to
Disney right watching their stock
collapse watching thousands literally
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people canceling Disney plus not going
to the parks uh now in the fight with
Florida and they've lost a bunch of
their special regulations and tax
exemptions and a whole bunch more and
now these beer companies going woke I
mean first off who do you think if
you're Bud Light or your Miller Lite or
your Coors Light or any of these
freaking beers who do you think buys
your beer do you think it's mostly women
or mostly men it's obviously mostly men
it's mostly men who look kind of like
Joe Rogan or Jack Carr it's not mostly
women who are like the chick in the ad
what's her name again Alana Glazer or
something it's like what are they
possibly thinking but they are they are
actually self-immolating they're pouring
gasoline on their heads and they're
destroying their products Bud Light
cannot get off the shelves right now it
they have completely freaking wrecked
the company and this thing about how
it's somehow bad
if you are messaging and trying to sell
something to dudes that you might show a
chick
look it's not my thing but if you're a
guy and you're into chicks it's cool
it's old school good for you it's just
great you like chicks in bikinis and
they make you want to drink beer though
you probably shouldn't drink that much
beer because you're going to get a beer
belly and chicks and bikinis usually
want a fitter dude so there's some
issues there but that's not the point
they are destroying these companies
check that check this out so this is
from Molson Coors which owns Miller Lite
and Coors this is an internal ad so this
was not publicly this this was not put
out as a as an advertisement to the
public this was internal messaging to
their own employees that got leaked out
and look how wokeness man give the devil
is due it destroys everything
at motion cores we know that diversity
equity and inclusion matter
diversity is a good thing because
everyone is unique in their experiences
points of views and the brands they
identified with
our point of view is that our employees
need to be as diverse as our consumers
who are Acid versus our products
it's part of our
2021-2023 Workforce strategy we have
challenged ourselves to increase our
representation of Professionals of color
both in the U.S and Canada
we're also committed to increasing the
representation of women in our workplace
to be reflective of Market where we work
and live
and we expect to achieve one billion
dollars of spin with diverse suppliers
in the Americas
we have provided education and dedicated
training to all employees to increase
their awareness and understanding of how
diversity equity and inclusion are
embedded into our culture and since 2020
we have maintained an annual 1.5 million
dollar investment in community
organizations focus on social justice
equity and empowerment
as we look forward most employers will
continue to make diversity equity and
inclusion part of everything that we do
if you just bashed your head against
your desk for the last 38 seconds you're
very similar to me just absolutely
insane that line something to the effect
of our employees needs to be as diverse
as our customers what think how insane
that what do you mean what do you mean
if a third of your customers are black
lesbians then a third of your employees
should be black lesbians also to black
lesbians drink Coors Light I feel like
they would that seems that seems right
to me
um yeah Daphne yeah I got a big nod from
Daphne on that one black lesbians love
core is like it's all so idiotic if you
were making a product let's say you were
making a glass to put water in or a
coaster to put that glass on or a pen or
some chapstick
or a box of tissues how many things do I
have on this desk or a lens cap well I
don't know why this is on my desk right
now someone fixed that later
if you were doing any of those things
what would you do you'd be like all
right I've got this idea for a product
and I'm going to start a company here so
you have to fill out some paperwork now
first when you go to a lawyer and be
like ah can I get a can I get a black uh
partly handicapped lawyer possibly with
a little Native American uh in there
could you is that and then you build out
the product I don't want these type it's
so stupid these people are trying to
make beer guys generally drink beer I
don't really like beer I find if I have
even half a beer I get bloated I like
tequila okay and I don't care I assume
that most of the people making my
tequila are Mexican but frankly it
doesn't matter if you know how to make
tequila and you're Asian
you could be an Asian little person
making tequila that would be fine with
me too
so moronic but it continues people it
just continues
Anheuser-Busch is doubling down this one
is really like wait till you hear the
last line on this one Anheuser-Busch is
doubling down on their woke campaign to
rep to literally replace their white
employees look at this
right through the process to the very
end and it needs to become a part of the
Brand's DNA
[Music]
still 40 women 60 men still
predominantly white so there's still
work to be done having a more diverse
and inclusive environment will make us
our company future proof I would like to
live in a world where diversity and
inclusion is so ingrained in who we are
what we do that we don't need to have a
conversation about it
foreign
you can't make this up first off that
woman says that the company 60 white so
there's more work to be done she's
literally saying we've got to fire the
white people and they're putting that up
there like it's a good thing that's
number one the guy at the end I want to
live in a place where we have diversity
Equity inclusion it's so part of who we
are we don't even have to talk about it
and you know if you do talk about it
we've got a gulag for you these people
are completely insane but now that we've
proven to you that if you drink beer
you're gay and certainly if you work at
a beer company you're obviously a
lesbian or bipoc or uh you know you're
one of those things you're a furry or
something else you're someone's walking
you around like a dog there's a whole
bunch of stuff okay
it's not just beer it's not just beer
now we've got your two spirit whatever
it is uh it's the cars the cars are
going gay okay so Ford Motors put out
this ad this is uh to up you know we've
got the gay month coming June it's the
whole month of gayness uh they're
getting ahead of the game and they put
this out for pride month already here
you go
[Music]
my way
foreign
ER has a truck like this and uh Connor I
wasn't going to tell you but as a little
this is a little pre-birthday gift for
you we've out your car right now is
outside in the in the parking lot being
uh detailed we're rainbow in that whole
freaking thing and you're gonna drive it
around town very proud you straight
white freak
um that's one thing uh the other thing
think about it this way let's say gay
people are 10 of the population why what
is the obsession with marketing
everything towards gay trans whatever
and a gay and trans have nothing to do
with each other they're actually Arch
enemies sort of like Optimus Prime and
Megatron gays and trans should not like
each other because the trans want to
chop off the genitals of the gays let's
put that aside for a second uh why would
you be marketing to a very Niche
audience and who what gay person is
walking in when you want to buy a car
and you know okay so you're sitting
there you're looking at two trucks well
which one of these trucks is gayer is
this what is this truck do you do you
have this in Rainbow it's just none of
it makes any sense but they keep
bludgeoning us over the head with this
nonsense and for years nobody did
anything
then came along Florida man yeah Ron
DeSantis was like I've had just about
enough of your gay beer and your gay
cards and your gay cartoons
and we're gonna do something about it uh
you know what he's doing well yesterday
he officially signed the signed it it
had been a long time coming but they're
closing up the legislative session here
in Florida so he's signing a whole bunch
of stuff right now uh he officially
signed the bill which will ban trans
surgeries on minors which is a major
major win and hopefully this will be
exported throughout the entire country
obviously Cali isn't going to do it New
York's not going to do it et cetera et
cetera but hopefully as many states as
possible we'll see hey let's not Chop
genitals off kids that's a winning thing
let's go ahead and do it here's this
address
but when we do do the SB 254 this will
permanent Outlaw the mutilation of
minors it will Outlaw the surgical
procedures and experimental puberty
blockers for minors it will also require
any adults receiving these surgeries to
be informed about the irreversible
nature and about the dangers of the
procedures it will give Florida courts
temporary jurisdiction to intervene and
halt procedures for out-of-state
children you have actually some states
in this country that want to be a Haven
for these types of procedures and even
welcome minors without their parents
consent into some of their jurisdiction
we're obviously doing the opposite here
and I think this is this provision is
important this is going to create a way
to recover damages for injury or death
resulting from mutilating surgeries or
these experimental puberty blockers that
are given to a minor because what
happens they go through this then they
get older and this is a huge problem
they should be able to sue the physician
who hurt them and they're now going to
be able to with this law yeah everything
he said there it's true it's reality
based we all know it's right you should
not be giving these kids these puberty
blockers kids that are having all sorts
of confusions and they might have gender
dysphoria or whatever it might be some
of them will grow up let's just say to
be gay people some of them will grow up
to be straight some of them have all
sorts of other issues but we Don won't
let 12 year olds get tattoos without
parents permission but for some reason
you're allowed to chop their boobs off
and this idea that you know California
which is really where he was referring
to that it wants to become a sanctuary
Haven so literally if you are a 12 year
old who wants to transition and get
puberty blockers and the surgeries and
everything else and your parents say no
California could potentially take you in
against your parents wishes well the
least Florida can do it's more than
pretty much anywhere else is going to
try to hang that up in the courts so
that California can't just do that I
mean it is so freaking psychotic but
isn't hearing just the truth and and and
standing up for what is so obviously
right ain't it refreshing well you know
what we're also not going to do here in
Florida we're not going to force anyone
to use any of these ridiculous pronouns
DeSantis also signed something on that
front
this bill makes sure that Florida
students and teachers will never be
forced to declare pronouns in school or
be forced to use pronouns not based on
biological sex we never did this through
all of human history until like what two
weeks ago now this is something they're
having third graders declare pronouns
we're not doing the pronoun Olympics in
Florida it's not happening here and so
just to be clear guys none of this is
based in hate or bigotry or anything
else I know you know that but when
you're communicating some of this to
your friends well that means he hates
gay people he hates trans people no he
is defending kids and not offering
endless confusion imagine trying you
know we just obviously my kids are both
under one right so they're not
communicating in English super well yet
we're working on it we're doing pretty
well actually but we had my uh two of my
nephews and my niece here who are a bit
older all under 10 but like you know
five to ten we had them over and it's
like to sit with an eight-year-old and
try to confuse them about gender or
pronouns or anything else it is so
absolutely insane so all we are doing
here in Florida is doing the right
freaking thing which for some reason in
crazy times the right thing seems rather
extraordinary but in sane times it
wouldn't seem extraordinary and if we
lived insane times none of this would be
necessary here's a couple of the new
laws that scientists passed or just
signed on to just in these last days of
the legislative session real quick SB
254 is outlawing permanent mutilation of
minors that's one we just talked about
HB 1069 removing pronoun politics and
expanding parental rights in education
okay parents are going to know what
their kids are learning
hb1438 protecting child's innocence
hb1521 ensuring women's safety and HB
225 expanding access to Youth Sports and
by the way when it comes to Youth Sports
we also Don LED biological boys beat the
crap out of girls in wrestling I know
that's very edgy and out there but
that's what we do the point of all of
this guys as this Florida legislative
session comes to an end and as the
wokeness just keeps moving and as I said
it's gonna be even nuttier in June when
we have lgbt2 Spirit by Bach
ugly they ruined the rainbow of all the
things that they did right they've done
so much but that they put those other
colors and the triangle on the rainbow
and it's like
they ruined the freaking rainbow
Skittles Skittles I can't eat Skittles
anymore
but it's going to get crazier it's going
to get crazier and we have an election
coming and it's time for sanity dare I
say it's time for does sanity and
Governor DeSantis spent the last couple
days in Iowa and I think there is a
message that makes sense for the future
it occurred to me that you can have the
best Declaration of Independence in the
world you could have the best
constitution in the world but if you
don't have people that are willing
throughout throughout our history to
stand up put on that uniform risk their
lives and in many instances give that
last full measure of devotion then it
isn't going to amount to very much and
so we are not called upon to make
sacrifices of that magnitude but we're
also called upon to do battle in the
political Arena so what I say to you as
Republicans put on the full armor of God
take your stand stand firm for truth we
must fight the good fight we must finish
the race and we must keep the faith I
can tell you this I am proud of what
we've done in Florida I'm thankful we're
Governor Reynolds and the team have done
in Iowa but I've only begun to fight
thank you all God bless you it's so
great to be in Iowa
thank you so much
thank you God bless you all
I'm gonna have to be shiny it doesn't
have to be perfectly TV ready or
anything else the truth and standing up
for what you believe in I know you get
it I know you get it check this out this
morning Time Magazine is uh doing a
piece on DeSantis they made him look
very it doesn't even look like him like
if you showed me that it looks like a
doesn't that look like an AI version of
him he's scalping an orange there which
obviously we grow a lot of oranges here
in Florida and there might be another
reference to a per a certain orange
person but they put out this piece in
Time Magazine on DeSantis there was one
particular part that my buddy Dave were
a boy you guys know Dave or boy he's
been on the show many times from
Claremont Institute he he pinned this
one that I thought this was interesting
here's just one little piece of it he
wrote or this is what they wrote in time
and Dave caught it by operationalizing
the culture War into a set of concrete
policies DeSantis has transformed the
nation's third most populous state what
was once the butt of jokes about Gators
and retirees is now the swaggering
Southern their entinged free state of
Florida where men or men woke his broke
and business is booming twelve hundred
new residents arrive every day it's in
the air it's everywhere it's amazing
says former GOP representative David
Jolly no fan of the vibe shift it's
between neighbors it's when you go to
restaurants it's when you go to schools
you're on one side and people know it a
Florida native Jolly is considering
moving his family out of the state what
you might find hilarious about this as
they're talking about GOP representative
David Jolly so you'd be like oh he's a
republican obviously he likes DeSantis
and they put him in there because he's
in MSNBC contributor so the Republican
they got to comment on what's Happening
here in Florida who says that neighbors
are now against neighbors and everything
else and he's considering leaving
Florida he's an MS NBC pardon my
French contributor it's just so blatant
and ridiculous and I'm sorry David Jolly
go mutilate eight children's genitals in
Cali go get out man I've got a few bucks
left in the thing here I'll throw it for
you
good things are happening trust me guys
like they really are if you can sort of
see through the fog and there's a lot of
fog right now uh good things really are
happening uh we're gonna get to a Ruben
report locals Community Q a uh if you
join right now we could probably get an
extra question or two in uh Ruben
report.locals.com let me talk to you
guys about Cozy Earth which I freaking
love cozy Earth uh you know their luxury
bedding and loungewear transforms lives
by offering the softest most luxurious
and responsibly sourced products in the
world they start with selecting only the
best suppliers with an eye towards
quality responsible production Cutting
Edge technology and premium materials
after a long day of fighting for freedom
and curbing Joe Biden's radical woke
agenda there's nothing more than I love
than resting in my cozy Earth bed sheets
and I love the shorts the sweatpants
they've got great stuff guys you've
heard me rave about Cozy Earth and
they're incredibly soft and luxurious
bedding while I'm not alone there are
literally thousands of customers who
have left five star reviews on their
website like this one from Tammy after
eyeing these for nearly four years I
finally pulled the trigger now I wish I
wouldn't have deprived myself of such an
incredible yet affordable luxury OMG
don't hesitate they are a gift from
Heaven I couldn't agree more cozy
earthcraft's luxury goods that transform
your lifestyle their products are made
from responsibly sourced viscous from
bamboo cozy Earth offers a hundred night
sleep trial sleep on it wash it out try
it out if you're not completely in love
just send it back for a full refund be
sure to check out their 10-year warranty
as well and right now you can save up to
35 percent on cozy Earth go to
cozyearth.com Dave and be sure to enter
my promo code Dave at checkout to save
35 all backed by a hundred night trial
that's cozyearth.com and if you live in
Florida you can still wear sweatpants
because they're light and soft and
smooth and nice okay here we go
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
Richard says hi Dave you and Michael
malice both say these people are idiots
we have nothing to fear from them I just
watched the fetterman clip and I don't
fear Him I fear the rig voting process
don't you think that until Pennsylvania
and other states Institute a sane legal
voting system that all the talk of who's
running in 24 is pre-2020 election
thinking okay so this is a great point
now first off the point that malice and
I have made when I always you know
yesterday we did quite a bit of it like
this is not the best of the best we're
not up against the best of the best
whether it's Joe Biden or Kamala Harris
or fetterman or Dianne Feinstein like
this is not the best of best this is an
old decrepit mentally compromised
physically compromised group of people
and we can beat them and we have better
ideas and all that stuff your point
though is okay that may be true but if
the elections are still screwy in places
like Pennsylvania
so that a guy like fetterman can beat a
guy like Dr Oz or if the Democrats are
going to do drop boxes or the Litany of
other things that they seem to do the
early voting and malins and all that no
IDs in California et cetera then it
doesn't matter whether whether their
candidates are good or bad you're
completely right about that uh I can
tell you this I know that there is a
movement in certain States I don't know
how much of this is like fully Public
public but I know that there is a
movement in certain States blue states
by Republicans to start doing the same
things the Democrats are doing not to
break the law but if Democrats are going
to do drop boxes if Democrats are going
to do all of these things then
Republicans will do them as well so
you're right there is no and this is one
of the big problems that we have right
now so many of us regardless of what
side of the aisle you're on we don't
have great faith in the system why would
why would any sane person right now have
great faith that let's look at two
states for example California where you
do not have to show an ID just really
think about that that is Banana Republic
level stuff when I voted in California
for the recall for Gavin Newsom I walked
in there I tried to show the guy my ID
and he was like no no no no it turned
out he knew me he's like Dave don't
worry about it but it had nothing to do
with that
they don't want to see your ID all they
want to know is they ask you for your
name and your address and then they look
in some sort of book so literally what I
could have done the next day was go to a
different polling station and said I
know my neighbor's name and I know his
address I could have walked in and
pretended to be my neighbor so there is
no reason to feel that the California
election system is is
um you shouldn't feel you shouldn't feel
any confidence in it not only that but
when they sent everybody mail-in ballots
on that you know they send you this mail
invalid it's folded like this and the
way they did it in California you may
remember I did a video on this about a
year and a half ago
when if you folded it there's only a
certain amount of ways you can fold
something like this right you can fold
it this way this way whatever it is and
then you put it in the envelope all you
had to do was put it up to the light and
no matter which way you could have
folded it you could see if you voted for
Larry Elder or not if you voted yes or
no on the recall then who you were
voting for so it is designed to break
your confidence in the system and then
when it comes to a place like
Pennsylvania let's not forget that in
the 2020 election Trump was crushing it
in Pennsylvania then around midnight
what happened a pipe burst in
Philadelphia shut down the voting and
then everything gets weird and all of
the Dropbox stuff stuff and everything
else so I I'm actually not sitting here
saying that the election wasn't legit I
I don't know any more than you do but
what I do know is there's enough
um
let's say there's enough questions in
the in the pool that we gotta think this
thing through and I think we have to
fight the same way they would fight
whatever the legal means are to fight
for a fair election is what we have to
do I would also say and this is
certainly what they don't they don't
want to hear this in Pennsylvania or
California there are ways to secure your
elections you do it like Florida does
you've got to show an ID they double
check everything it's done by paper you
put it in yourself someone's standing
there
etc etc Danielle says please answer the
following question in your civil rights
preacher voice
can you tell us about a time that you
discovered that the adults were fibbing
to you suggestion Santa Tooth Fairy
birds and the bees or anything else okay
so I have to do this in my preacher
voice and I'll tell you a time that I
was lied to by parent by uh parents or
adults or something okay so Peter boys I
do declare that one time my parents lied
to me was around
1994 when I came home from college I was
a freshman at the University of
Binghamton New York and I came home and
I said to my parents because a lot of my
friends over there were smoking the pot
and I said to my parents do you did you
in your day ever smoke the marijuana and
I sent it straight to their faces and I
remember them looking at each other with
a gleam in the eye and they both said to
me that they had never smoked the pot
but I knew in my Heart of heart that
they had spoke to the Doobie yeah how is
that pretty good pretty good pretty good
then nine eight all right pretty good
yeah yeah I I remember because I had
never even drank a beer in high school
never smoked pot anything whole freshman
year of college too I really never did
anything and that but a lot of my
friends were smoking pot and I remember
going home and asked my friends well did
you guys smoke pot back then and I just
had a feeling that they weren't fully
telling me the truth maybe glaucoma
related who knows talway says uh Dave I
don't know if you've seen the report of
the Florida school teacher saying
parents should lose their rights to kid
to their kids when they send them to
public school or the report that just
came out about California wanting to
restrict parental access to school
campuses but I'd love to get your take
on what feels like a disturbing Trend in
the education sector so I I don't know
the specific one you're talking about in
Florida but this the general theme
of that somehow these are not your kids
these are the state's kids or that when
you put your kid in a classroom that
that teacher has more
um Direct
ownership over the child than you do
this is a real theme coming out of the
left these days this it takes a village
these are not your kids we're hearing
this all the time from Kamala Harris we
used to hear it from Hillary Clinton
we're hearing it from all of these
teachers again I could tell you guys and
and I'm just feeling this so strongly as
a parent of an eight-month-old and a six
month old like it is my job as a parent
to make sure that they get the right
ideas and they are not infected with the
wrong ideas and and basically abused by
state employees and God knows what uh
this this you hope that you can put them
in a class it would be nice right if we
could all believe in public education to
the point that you would get an
education I don't know like I got I went
to all public schools growing up and I
remember going
elementary junior high school we never
talked about my teacher's sexuality we
never talked about our sexuality there
was health class in seventh grade the
guy put a condom on a banana we all
laughed but that was pretty much the
extent of it we didn't ask him if he was
wearing a dress after school he probably
was but nobody knew so it didn't matter
but this is the stuff they are doing
they want to basically take and mold the
mind of young people into something that
ultimately will destroy the family and
once you destroy the family bottom up
what do you do you start destroying
communities you just start destroying
cities states and the whole freaking
thing so
fight it like we're fighting it in
Florida Mike says do you miss California
no papa hook says if DeSantis runs
should I do a little more on that I
don't I don't miss anything about do any
of you miss anything about do you miss
anything Phoenix you grew up there do
you miss anything nothing Connor you
were only there for about a year do you
miss anything
what
in an in and out all right in and out
burger yes I do I actually kind of Miss
in and out I will grant you that Daphne
you lived your whole life in the LA area
just your family well we're gonna send
the plane and rescue everybody we're
sending a plane
the Florida Gator plan we're gonna send
them get Daphne's whole family here Papa
hook says if DeSantis runs four and wins
the nomination what is his plan to get
Trump's endorsement and keep him from
running as a third party candidate I had
some good ideas look I think at this
point we can go on the assumption that
DeSantis is running I sense that it's
going to happen any day now probably
like Monday or Tuesday let's just let's
just go with that for just a moment I
think one of the disappointments that
I've had in the last two months is you
guys know if you watch this show with
any regularity you know for months I've
been trying to do my best not really to
go after Trump even though I I clearly
think DeSantis is the better choice at
this point I've tried to be fair about
it but I have called out the nonsense
when it's come unfortunately Trump has
gone so in on the nonsense said this is
a rhino and a global like it's been so
ridiculous and it's not working by the
way
it's been so ridiculous that he's done a
certain amount of damage there now I
would say this you really got to
remember this I know in the In the Heat
of the battle and on the day-to-day
basis politics it's like I could never
vote for that person because he said
this at the end of the day do you want
Joe Biden or Kamala Harris or Gavin
Newsom as president or do you do want
Rhonda said this or Donald Trump so
whoever wins there there will be some
meeting there will be some meeting and
hopefully they will put those pieces
together I would say it's much more
incumbent on Trump to clean that up
because the DeSantis people for the most
part and I certainly include myself in
this no one's no one's really angry at
the Trump supporters or at Trump like I
wish his behavior was a little bit
better but I get it he is what he is the
Trump people are like seemingly the I'm
talking about the base of the base not
the average nominal supporter like
they're really like you know they've
gone all in on that DeSantis is the most
evil person around and it's like no he's
actually the best governor in the entire
country and Florida is flourishing and
that's why Trump lives here and that's
why his kids live here and all of his
grandkids live here and everything else
so there's a disconnect there that's
going to have to be dealt with but I I
as nasty as politics can get and trust
me it's barely gotten nasty so far I
hope that they'd be able to you know
just erase it whiteboard it blank it out
and start over Amy says if you could
describe your recent trip in one word
what would that be
affirming
about affirming I think it would be
affirming it was it was very affirming I
think it was affirming to me personally
I think philosophically religiously
professionally
um it was you know not only well
especially the Israel part to me
um having been there before but seeing
some of the good things that were going
on there and catching up with some old
friends and you know the thing that I'm
constantly talking about on the show
about how do we take some things from
the old world and still blaze a trail to
the new world that that really seems to
me what the very essence of what Israel
is uh so it's it's deeply connected to
what I'm trying to do on this show I
would say but also you know to take the
whole team there and have everybody uh
you know we did all the tours and again
we're going to put this doc out probably
in the next two to three weeks or so
this mini dock that we shot there with
some interviews and tours and wandering
around Jerusalem and and a whole bunch
more but it was just very affirming of
uh that I'm kind of doing what I'm
supposed to be doing I suppose uh vinay
says hey Dave I call caught up on a few
of the Vex shows during your trip abroad
he seems very feisty and on point can't
wait for the primary debates with him
what do you think of his messaging look
I you know I was the first guest on
vivex podcast Vivek has been on this
show a couple times I like Vivek I think
he's he's gone like a little overboard
in some of the DeSantis attacks but okay
let's just put that aside I think having
Vivek on stage is is really excellent
for Republicans you know if you just
look at it this way if you have Trump on
stage assuming Trump's going to do it
Trump is now saying he may not even
debate which is ridiculous but because
that's where that's where he shines
right at least supposedly if you have
Trump DeSantis Nikki Haley
vivec let's say Tim Scott and you throw
in one more it's not Mike Pompeo said
he's out but you give me Mike Pence
let's say you really have a wide
selection of people to look at with
different opinions on different things
with different resumes but they're all
clearly they're all accomplished
professional people like Vivek as a
businessman DeSantis as a governor Trump
as a former president and a businessman
um they all Nikki Haley as a successful
governor and Ambassador at the UN like
these are people who deserve to be on a
stage now contrast that with what the
Democrats put up last time it was such a
ridiculous clown show of unqualified
people I mean Pete bootage who was the
mayor of South Bend Indiana who
accomplished absolutely nothing a tiny
little town in Indiana who then they
made Transportation secretary only
because of his sexuality those were the
types of people that they had up there
or just a bunch of people with really
bad ideas who had no real support like
Kamala Harris or uh Elizabeth Warren Etc
et cetera so I'm glad that Vivek is
involved I'd like to see him you know
right now it seems like he's just the
attack dog for Trump to go after
DeSantis I'd like to see him even that
out a little bit but getting him up
there you know he's right on all the
woke stuff obviously he's right on ESG
and a bunch more and I think he's a good
guy so there you go uh Connor says hey
Dave love the Reuben report locals
Community love the shows and I have a
question if this uh oh it's this will
you ever shave your beard off I don't
think so as I've said before I'm more
beard than man now I look back at my old
shows I just look better with a beard
some people they look better shaven some
people look better with a beard I think
generally speaking Yeah I'm a beard guy
now it's too late for me as uh Darth
said to Luke you know there's nothing if
I take this beard off I'll die that's it
that's how it works kind of like Samson
Eric says Dave is it time for the
lesbians and gays to break away from the
rest of the alphabet Mafia since they
have become so militant and insane yeah
I mean it's why these letters have
nothing to do with each other I have
nothing to do with these trans radical
lunatics I don't have that much to do
with lesbians quite frankly uh but
they're all right you know you know
whatever it's cool
um these things have nothing to do with
each other and your sexuality doesn't
Define who you should be friends with or
where you should want to live or
anything else but they've somehow made
your sexuality an ideology that's what's
so dangerous you know when you see like
a gay flag somewhere a flag is supposed
to connotate usually Flags connotate
like I don't know a country so you can
have a sort of if you see a flag of
America you have a set of ideas that
that probably means that makes sense and
that's different than say the flag of
Cuba or the flag of China they have
their own set of ideas that their Flags
represent but what does a gay flag
represent it doesn't really represent
anything other than your sexual
preference let's say but that's not
really something to be putting on a flag
it's all so insane and I'm telling you
guys this this trans thing it's there
there is no
the trans movement is far more anti-gay
than the Christian right they will pin
the Christian right they're the bigots
the Christian right is not trying to
chop the genitals off gay people it's
the trans people are trying to do it
that seems worse okay okay Jeffrey says
what tourist attractions did you visit
in Budapest did you like the food I saw
you visit visited the house of
parliament but I wonder what else you've
seen you know our trip there was so
packed with so many interviews we didn't
do much touristy stuff we wandered
around the Danube River and we walked in
we went to Parliament uh we had lunch at
Jamie Oliver's Restaurant which I assume
is one of the budapest's finest locales
uh I ate I had dinner with Jordan
Peterson at actually a great restaurant
it was called Felix which was on the
other side of the river from Parliament
uh really really nice and why don't we
tell the people what hotel we stayed at
because it was really cool what was the
hotel the Clark Hotel really kind of
funky cool like modern but goth and just
a lot of Textures in the hotels was
really cool uh what else did we do there
man it's been what a blur these last
couple weeks have been what else yeah we
did I mean that was the main thing it
was Parliament it was talking to people
the show with Jordan what's that
yeah we walked through some castles and
a whole bunch of other stuff yeah it was
very cool I wish we would have had more
time there and we'll definitely go back
uh Joe says the Durham report was
finally released and exposed the
malfeasance of the FBI in regards to
russiagate in your opinion what's worse
the fact that the powers that be spent
years lying to the American public or
the fact that there are still people out
there that believe the BS even though
the lies have been exposed look
the lying we cover it all the time right
I could spend the rest of my life just
playing clips of MSNBC and CNN and
everybody else lying about Russia I
could play clips of Adam Schiff and I
could play clips of all of the people
right Hillary lying about you know
Donald Trump's an illegitimate President
we could do that all day long
um the problem I guess really is that
they released this Durham report and
it's not going to really change anything
a bunch of us that that knew that either
knew it was kind of nonsense or or just
weren't fully swallowing it whatever you
want to say
um sure it strengthens our belief that
we were kind of right about this but do
you think that the average viewer of the
view even if they were to cover this or
the average reader of the New York Times
do you think they'll change their
opinion do you think they'll go back and
be like boy you know
for these last six years I've been
running around screaming that Donald
Trump was a Russian asset he was working
with the Russians to steal an election
and actually it does turn out not to be
true and I might have to rethink a whole
bunch of things if I got that wrong and
that's what the problem is but this is
why I also think the truth will set you
free you must fight for the truth
because if you fight for the truth a
certain amount of people will wake up a
whole bunch won't and that will always
be disappointing and there will be
people in your personal life who you
will want to wake up and you will try to
wake up and you will not be able to wake
up but you may as well try and and I
hope that more and more people as
mainstream media collapses
um we'll turn to Independent Outlets
like this I mean we know this is
happening it's literally happening in
real time uh and and find out something
a little bit closer to the truth
I think it's as simple as that rich says
when can we expect having an option to
download content for offline listening
that's the only reason I still have uh
YouTube on my phone
excuse me Spotify and even Fox Nation
have this as an option maybe something
to build within Rumble and look locals
yes we're on it we're working on it
trust me we're working on a whole bunch
of stuff we just got our main uh
programmer out of Ukraine he's now here
in Miami working at the locals office uh
and we are working on a whole bunch of
things but yeah the offline download is
one of those things uh also I mentioned
on the show the other day
that Rumble announced on Tuesday that we
have acquired the call-in app call-in is
a really cool technology that I've
wanted to use forever but I could I
didn't want you know I send people to
rumble and and locals obviously I didn't
want to send people to another app but
we are going to incorporate the call-in
features into locals and basically I'll
be able to do live live like Old School
radio call-in shows like AM radio and
it'll be for paid subscribers so it's
not going to be all the trolls just
calling me and having to deal with that
nonsense but so you pay a couple bucks
and we'll start doing live radio shows
like that I think it's an absolutely
awesome feature so we're building out a
whole bunch more just patience guys I
know everyone wants everything
immediately and I get it and I think
before I was in the tech game I was
probably like why can't you do this
tomorrow these things take a little time
we're also you know we're trying to
build everything ourselves because we
don't want to be reliant on everybody
else we don't want to be Reliant
certainly on Amazon or the big boys so
we have to build this stuff ourselves
that so it does take a little time uh
Kerry says you know how Biden and
Company abandoned zillions of dollars
worth of Weaponry when they pulled out
of Afghanistan could it be that this was
done deliberately so that the military
industrial complex in order to replace
what was lost be called upon to supply
gazillions more dollars worth of
military equipment I like zillions and
gazillions
um I think there could be some
legitimacy to that absolutely I mean
when you see now those pictures or
videos of all of the stuff that we left
there the the helicopters the tanks the
Humvees all of it it's like that does
have to be replaced at some point so
does this become just the sort of
endless sort of feeding of the machine
oh we've lost all that stuff we better
replace it with other stuff because you
know the way the government operates the
budgets always go up if the military
let's say any any department is given a
million bucks for a calendar year if
they don't spend that million bucks
their budget goes down so they always
overspend so that their budget goes up
no one could run a business like this
but I guess it's pretty good when you've
got the printing press David says what
was your favorite part about your trip
to Israel
um you know I have to say I I really
love Jerusalem I I knew that I was going
to love Tel Aviv and I've been there a
few times Tel Aviv is is sort of the
it's like the fun and the Heart of the
country in a certain sense of like music
and food and everyone every restaurant
is open till 4am and everything's packed
everywhere and it's young and there's
just like because that's they the
country's so small that that's where all
of you know the people in their 20s and
30s 40s that's where they all congregate
and it's just like a Non-Stop endless
party and beautiful people and all that
stuff Jerusalem which I've been to
several times over the years but I never
spent like five straight days there and
being in Jerusalem and walking around
and seeing the mix and I mean we we
posted a couple pictures of it the mix
of Orthodox Jews and religious Muslim
women side by side at the same shops and
everything else it is simply not what
the media would show you it's not what
our evil communist Liars like Rashida
Talib who tell you this place is about
apartheid whatever dare show you there's
so much more coexistence there going I
think really probably my favorite thing
there was going to the the main Market
in Jerusalem uh Friday afternoon before
Shabbat so this is where all the people
are at the market and they've got
everything you can think of there they
got fish they got meat they got booze
they got breads they everything spices
all this kind of stuff
um and just there's such an energy in
there it's just it's wild like you
really I can't really explain it we did
take some video in there so we'll we'll
show you some video and I did buy some I
bought some uh some teas uh which I've
been actually this is a little maybe
I've said too much related to Dave
rubin's tequila that I'm working on but
I've been taking some of these little
tea leaves and little pomegranate things
and I've been uh soaking some tequila in
them and I'm working on a little
something so stay tuned on that uh Megan
says have you read Rod Dreyer's Book
Live not by lies I do feel like we are
in a life or death game of chess the
stakes are very high if we lose total
transparency I have not read it yet but
we do have it here and I did interview
rod in Budapest look at that right there
I mean that view ain't bad that's
Parliament right behind us and Rod's
hair should get some sort of award he
says he has not found the proper Barber
yet in Budapest so he goes back to
America he lives part-time in Hungary
part-time in America but he's a great
thinker uh and and he's fighting for
truth and he he really loves it was very
obvious to me and you'll see the
interview we'll put the whole thing up
do we know when we're putting that up
yet we're not sure yet right
yeah we're figuring that out we're still
plotting out a few things from the trip
um but like he just loves what Hungary
is fighting for that they're saying hey
we're a country here we have an identity
we have a culture we don't want it
overrun with immigrants we want to
defend our borders we don't want people
in Brussels to make decisions for us and
a whole bunch more it's so clean and
clear and obvious and that was one of my
main takeaways from the trip whether it
was in Hungary or in Israel like
countries have the right I mean this is
what national conservatism is all about
that you have a right it's the whole
point of nation states like if you live
in a country the country can set the
agenda and once the country exports that
agenda to people in Brussels or to
globalists or the wef or whatever it
might be you're not really a country
anymore yeah you live in a geographic
area with a bunch of people but there's
no purpose for your nation and I think
if we can get back to that it will help
and you know the beauty of America is
we're doing it in the federal style
first right the Federalist style we're
doing it at the state level and then we
can build out that National project I
think it emanates here first from
Florida and then goes out that way and I
think we can save America I really do
guys we've got a post game show coming
up in just moments at
reubenreport.locals.com we leave you I
apologize in advance with Adam Schiff
and I'll see everybody else in a couple
seconds
possible for the evacuations to finish
up before August 31st
I think it's possible but I think it's
uh very unlikely given the number of
Americans who still need to be evacuated
the number of sivs the number of others
who are members of the the Afghan press
Civil Society leaders women leaders it's
hard for me to imagine all of that can
be accomplished between now and the end
of the month
foreign
[Music]